[Music]  i really am glad you're here  i just want you to enjoy your weekend  [Music]  you taste like oregano i can feel  the water  you need to put all that away i haven't  had my coffee yet  excuse me  don't fail me no  dear jordan i don't fail just take one  look at your mother  marry me  yes  that will tell you what i think  beautiful is i'm ready  your father wrote that i'm ready  he wrote this whole thing just for you  [Music]  love's choice jordan  and real love  means you have to sacrifice  but pain is temporary  real love lasts forever  but remember jordan  you have to fight for  [Music]  see it exclusively in movie theaters  this christmas  [Music]  you